and then we didn't realize
that that was the stage so we were all
on stage and all those people were like
yeah
no no no no
there's a whole studio tonight
whole thing going on back here
[Music]
i feel really good about my
said oh well then why aren't you like
so
upbeat about it because you're sad huh
you're a sad guy and i go you're stoic
aren't you bro i was like i'm a sad guy
what are you talking about and then they
then they said things about like my
brother because i talked about how my
brother passed yes and i'm telling they
they used all this [ __ ] against me and
it was the [ __ ] worst and i was like
i'll never do
anything
like that ever again in hollywood ever
[ __ ] again it's like the worst
[ __ ] experience did the show ever
come out hell no i was glad oh okay
because coleman happened okay
copenhagen was like but it was so weird
and they wanted me to like cry
they were like using you as a storyline
not necessarily trying to highlight your
comments yeah it was so [ __ ] yeah
because there were girls who came out
against tyra banks for that same thing
on america's next top model because she
used to have this um reality show where
she would choose like 15 girls or
something nick did you puke
what happened something happened
it hasn't been recording yeah i'm
guessing wasn't recording
the whole time
one more time
one more time
i'm so sorry
just start now it might be funny from
this point
it was in the middle of his
his story we started uh
wait which part did we just we'll just
start fresh should we just do this every
week now yeah
welcome to kids
[Applause]
he said i have to take it before it is
my job to press record but i mean
i come out i'm like can you set up your
computer he is literally laying on the
couch like this with it like
he's like draw me like one of your
french girls
in my defense you were doing reads with
brandon
20 minutes before chin walked out
[Laughter]
i am lashing out it's not healthy
oh my god can we get a lash out
oh my god is it lash out no it's too
much my voice is kind of trash because i
was singing that nicholas shea song all
week last week which one what song oh no
here we go
i won't do it again it's okay you sang
it really well
oh wait shut up no you did i didn't know
you'd know all the words you knew the
bridge like free choice
you knew it all
it's literally one of my favorite songs
like how could i not know it i know i'm
gonna you know
just to like fill everyone in we were
recording and it didn't uh record all of
this stuff to review
we're gonna pick up where we left off
and we're talking about reality shows
trying to like produce a narrative
because you were auditioning for a show
man these hoes try to come up on me man
they was like ooh
you sad huh i was like i ain't sad and
then you hit a [ __ ] then i hit a [ __ ]
i would never hey
okay
so if anything comes out about chappelle
it wasn't him it wasn't his fault if
anything comes out about me
the only person he hit ever is meatball
and that's different
you know meatball probably hit him first
for as angry as i've
been crazy as i was my last time hitting
someone
actually you know i was about to lie
that wasn't my last time i thought i was
when i was 14. but no i had what was it
then i i think it was when i was 21. i
shoved someone at a wu-tang clan concert
oh not like in a mosh pit setting like
uh like you were trying to fight he was
drunk he was like shoving up on these
girls
ain't nothing to [ __ ] with
hey let's go
you hit someone with a skateboard too
didn't you i never did oh i've never hit
someone with a skateboard i thought you
told me that
i told you that maybe oh no maybe you
told your teacher that or something no
teacher thought you did sorry the guy i
know the guy i beat up told my teacher
that i beat him beat him up with uh my
skateboard in a bat
both of those items yeah both of those
items i was like what the [ __ ]
why would i do that yeah was it streets
of rage or something she's a rage what's
up video og video game uh before we take
this magic mind which you can get at
magic mind dot co slash dark promo code
dark for 20 off i do want to tell
everybody they should subscribe to the
audio on spotify and apple podcast we're
trying to get more advertisers and we
need the audio numbers up everybody's
been finding us on youtube but the audio
numbers are lack yeah listen to audio
yay
subscribe rate review apple pi actually
it's they they actually switched it on
both platforms you don't subscribe to
podcasts anymore you follow podcasts yes
yeah that's that's the new lingo you
follow the podcast what do you type in
to search it uh cats after dark k-a-t-s
after dark nice
cheers magic mine hey we get to do it we
get to meatball made a great point
before i yelled at him uh i need to take
this before the show as well so i don't
forget to press before that's what i was
cause you did lash out didn't you yeah
cheers
because as everybody knows magic mine is
a once daily matcha based shot that'll
has 30 milligrams of caffeine and if you
take it every day you're going to have a
nice zen focus
and you'll be able to make an incredible
song yeah the song was so dope i'll
listen to that again do you have that do
we have enough to drink these later
because we got to shoot a little vid for
uh i think oh [ __ ] i thought he said
like i think we do he's he said a lot
right huh yeah yeah i i i think i have a
box here you know what's so funny about
me freaking out on
magic mine what i read how much is like
in a [ __ ] energy drink
in terms of caffeine yeah oh yeah i told
you it was all in your head what gives
you exactly
what gives you energy for magic mind is
not the caffeine caffeine doesn't even
give you energy it just shuts off the
receptors it makes you feel tired
it's the natural it's the 11 other
natural ingredients like the ashwagandha
yeah it's beautiful this time of year
hey nick's killing it
[Laughter]
i read about magic uh do reads for magic
might about four times a
[Laughter]
all week usually the guy the other guy i
do it by podcast with pat just talks
about how much it makes him [ __ ] his
wife more and he's oh wow yeah and he's
also said that uh his nanny has uh
gotten into his refrigerator taking the
magic mind and now she quit because she
drove off with the ferrari because she's
just advanced that much
yeah
oh i actually believe that story
wake up and going
time i've ever clearly felt productive
when i drink i think i need to take
another sip mixing up the matcha with
the honey make it hit do more stress
let's live a better life
making magic drinking magic mine
[Music]
good vibes
we'll get you that footage that'll be
part of it okay yeah that was great uh
good good stuff good stuff magic mine i
love that song literally listen to it
like it's such a catchy fun right i
actually like this
i like it someone doesn't [ __ ] hit
you up for a jingle by now
right now i love you making jingles it's
fun yeah yeah jingle bells good at it
did you hear dosia cats taco bell jingle
recently no but i love you it's
hilarious first of all doji cat has the
best tick tock page ever really like
literally ever she's hilarious on it so
uh last week she had posted a video when
she seems like she's like maybe hi or
out of it she's like guys this is a
secret and i just want you to know that
if you see a jingle pop up for a company
that rhymes with michael bell
then like i am contractually obligated
to do it it's gonna sound trash but like
[ __ ] with me on this on the next day she
releases what the jingle was and it's i
guess taco bell had asked her to make a
jingle about them bring their mexican
pizza back and it's just hilarious
because you know that she hates it but
she's still she's like promoting it
and and also they're bringing that
mexican pizza back i think it's pretty
good yeah it's coming back i don't
remember the mexican people really do
you know the choco tacos
yeah okay oh those are fire tacos are
good with the mexican pizza it was like
uh
crispy tortillas
fried beans [ __ ] yeah dude they're
unbelievable is this the the song or
just her uh roasting the news she's so
pretty
she's gorgeous she's so tight too like
she seems so cool
seems less than thrilled with the final
product they want me to rap about
mexican pizza so i just want to give you
a heads up before you see that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's contractual yeah
and don't even think about calling get a
jingle by the way i banned that word
within my team jingle we're not allowed
to say that dosia sets up the song with
eyes that say internally screaming hi
i made a song
dude i don't know how much i paid you
because i love it so much
discontinue it a year ago and uh this
led me to this monstrosity of a beat
that i just made
and um i wrote a verse and i hope you
like it and if you don't i understand
and she begrudgingly plays her she's
gorgeous
i got beans i need meat i need a shell
with a sausage
mexican pizza
[Music]
despite her worries about the subject
matter dozier sounds great on it it's
still bob status and all her hesitation
may end up being a brilliant form of
marketing
i bet they paid her a lot oh my god her
reach is so [ __ ] crazy
like there there are certain people who
just like across all platforms now are
like
mega stars that i haven't seen since i
want to say like the early 2000s like
superstars like tom cruise and johnny
depp like the new age is like the dosia
cats of the world yeah like addison
ray's like these tick talkers and like
new musicians are [ __ ] huge anderson
raised the uh yeah she's the girl yeah
the girl who just signed a multi
netflix
i can't say words deal yes and they
haven't done that in a minute they
haven't and a lot of people [ __ ] on her
for that because she doesn't have any
like acting experience
[Laughter]
she had done that magic mind is hitting
him right now
it's like an honest serum yeah
talent
i love her to a group where
she could be like one who doesn't like
she does have talent i don't know but in
general those tick tockers that like 60
million when they're dancing i think
she's definitely the smartest one out of
all the tick talkers because she's kind
of like whoever is managing her has kind
of put her on this career path to be
like an actual celebrity like working in
the industry rather than just like a
tick tocker
regardless of like her whether she has
talent or not like her
career trajectory is insane for two
years josh richards has done like the
same thing too yeah absolutely
uh he's just a podcast with uh dave
portnoy called bffs he was just another
wiggle dicker as dave portnoy used to
call them the popular tick tock guys uh
yeah and but but he's been able to like
move past just tick-tock platform and
now he's that podcast yeah yeah because
i imagine you gotta you get to a [ __ ]
point and then all of a sudden you use
like you're like i'm just going to keep
making these [ __ ] dance videos and i
don't know where the money comes from
from that besides like the tic tac has
like a the creator fund or whatever but
like i don't think that pays very much
it's it for the like for the house
sponsors right yeah but then
on tick tock i'm not i guess i'm not on
tick tock that much but it's like josh
richards doing like just this brand
is he doing a tick tock that he gets
paid directly from a brand to do a tick
tock for i don't know so from what i've
gathered it's that
some people will have like direct deals
with the brand to do tick tocks for like
i heard rumors about
different record labels paying tick
talkers to make
like a new dance
to their song to promote this artist and
so certain artists will blow up on that
app really quickly and then there are
also like
if you are smart with who is on your
team and you have a good manager they
then go get deals for you or different
projects you can invest in as like an
angel investor where you just throw
money at some [ __ ] and then like rake in
the
money later on yeah and so that's what
josh richards is doing i heard that he's
ver a very good businessman behind the
scenes and now he's getting into acting
his partner is a guy named michael gruen
who like uh i love michael gruen
you know i knew you knew how did you
know split second i was like oh
he knows michael gruen
and then i was like
he's a manager of a bunch of wiggle
dickers but he's there
he's like he's like 21 as well
[Music]
i mean and like you said venture capital
fund like just like
just a bunch of money that bunch of it's
like roulette wheel
of
my friend told me that uh he went to a
record label and he's like popular
singer
and all they cared about was tick tock
and like the guy was like what's your
tick tock numbers looking like and if it
wasn't like 1.5 2.5 mil all across the
board they were like we can't really do
anything with this that's so weird
that's all they care about joe made a
tick talk about that too
like
something along the lines of record
labels won't push you now the way that
they used to they basically tell you
like oh make a dance or like get viral
on tick tock like that's their answer
for marketing
that is the weirdest [ __ ]
a million dollars worth of game which is
another bar stool podcast if you guys
heard of
yeah yeah of course i have
you could say no because then i can give
a little bit more content i've never
heard of that what is it uh wallow and
gillow it's huge it like
in the rap game they just had um
would it be little duval on any they
like
they did a podcast over a million
dollars cash and it was like 50 people
it was the coolest podcast oh wait no i
think it's a little dark a little dark
yes
oh i know what you're talking about
there's like 30 people in the room
there's a million dollars on the table
smoke going anywhere and they're just
podcasting uh and it was it's [ __ ]
dope but they're just like very
influential in the hip hop community and
they have also said like tick tock has
surpassed radio if you're not getting
tick-tock play you ain't [ __ ] okay now
yeah yeah i guess i i guess that's fair
can i get a pen if it's away let's
[ __ ] turn this into little duval oh
wally way to [ __ ] little dirk
i'm sorry that was aggressive
that is interesting that you got it come
on
i feel like it's either a lack of trust
in me
i don't trust myself
that's what i wrote something
it's not you it's me
i can't love you anymore
i can't throw i can't throw a [ __ ]
ball but i can throw [ __ ] humans in
the air but no sound just bring up a
million dollars worth of games you know
what i mean a little dirk but hey that's
so if that's okay that makes sense
that's the way in the game now
and that's what it does that if it's
been doing that for music then you kind
of have to respect that but also
shouldn't you res like shouldn't you
expect more from your record label in
terms of marketing
yes
if it's an easy
if it's an easy way to uh market
then you kind of have to go there i
guess
right
yeah this podcast is good yeah drink
champs yeah
they're dope gilly the kid yeah that's
really the career that's what i thought
on the left right uh what's the homie's
name oh they're using a road caster
chin just picking up
on the technicals
hey this one hits dogs been dying for
like 10 minutes though there you go
this one hits doggy bone you can see all
the smoke we need a drink
i think that's to commemorate episode 10
of cats after dark i'm going to take
mushrooms on that show hey welcome to
cats after dark
[Music]
he just baby out of a cloud of smoke a
little dirk's place
when is episode 10 uh i don't know three
episodes i'll do it with you drive one
no you won't why not
don't say on a podcast that you're gonna
drive home on mushrooms it was a joke
it's a podcast
nick is out of the dog
trying not to hey nick you're doing
great you're doing great
hey nick this thing [ __ ] huh huh oh
yeah oh yeah all right uh i got it in
springfield missouri which by the way
mm-hmm
cool town
greatest city on earth wow the greatest
yeah pound for pound power bound what
about it is so great it's like i haven't
heard much of it
it's it's just [ __ ] amazing you know
they got a they got a bass pro shop
that's
three levels
so that's all that's going on there they
got
route 66 originated
out of springfield really yeah so say
something about that that's cool um they
got a visitor's center for when you go
to springfield i feel like you were just
hitting the weed pan and going to all
these places you're like
that's me on a bear where else you're
gonna do that
you know
like people have bare statues but not
you're like so happy and the the suicide
silence shirt on that on that bear you
look like you're going on a field trip
to where this is like a field trip photo
with a little bag lunch next how high
were you in this picture it wasn't high
at all really really yeah why it looks
like the sun's in his eyes of that why
do i look at what do you mean i look hot
a little bit like hi
no my eyes i mean when i smile my eyes
like squint more
fair
that's about it i was showing a tick
tock
that uh
it was like another a guy with a uh a
fellow guy with a prominent brow like my
mind does i get called caveman a lot
but uh it's actually
prominent brows you don't have to that's
why i don't wear sunglasses ever i never
have and i realize because i haven't
well this tick tock informed me that i
have like a natural shield of the sun
that you
do not have evolution you do dude
what are you talking about
i've never related to something more in
my life
you don't wear sunglasses no
that's you guys they used to call me
prominent
oh i was like damn that's crazy that's a
great name that's cool that is a great
pb yeah pb yeah like a pb j right that's
fair
i've said it before uh i don't know if
it's on old cats after dark but king of
this thing but i was like i almost
[ __ ] up your name because a little
brows is way better it's its own thing
but i almost said i almost corrected
brennan and said little brother wow
because it was the pun i remember you
texted that to me
[Laughter]
months after too you're like hey i was
gonna
you have to cover like little bow wow
songs and shot and flashback to me doing
hello what's his name little bow wow
song fourth grade talent show another
town show dude i did there was not a lot
going on at my school i won the talent
show hell yeah you did i think it was
the
okay basketball is my favorite sport oh
i like the way to dribble back
he's so cringey yeah
wasn't it no that's a cover yeah i could
do that no no yeah he covered that oh
who's the original little zane uh no uh
curtis blow i want to say basketball joe
yep what is it called basketball that's
just the name of basketball yeah type in
colonel's squad you're right okay now
basketball is my favorite i can hear the
old school one now because you hear the
flow right yeah that sounds like our our
boy that had the video we watched like
eight times in here which one uh the guy
who's sending the rap basketball in my
favorite sport
the guy would listen to oh with the
glisten forehead glisten don't worry
he did have that same thing that's the
eight that's like the 90s flower head
started glistening yeah get that towel
whip and yeah he was so it's funny can
we watch this video again yeah i
literally watch it all the time why did
it what was it and you found me i told
him
that you watch it all the time yeah yeah
and he's aware that he wrote back he was
so excited he said he was so
appreciative send me it again no oh i
got you you like michael you got to tell
me twice great movie
like mike fire movie yeah fire movie
such a good movie yeah i think yeah
curtis blow was the first to do that
where's that video
my voice sounds so bad i feel like a
nerd oh because you have a performance
coming up right in fullerton mm-hmm when
is it um
march 26th
and 4-10 at program skate shop
can people buy tickets or
just dollars yeah that's nice
[Laughter]
like ten dollars
i just left the way you said it
that's two months of king in this thing
one of the shows me and chen did that
took us for five bucks it was cool yeah
people came in wait did you get it
meatball chapelle what's your fan's name
[Music]
forehead starts to glisten i like it
more and more the more i hear it so
listen i got much time to describe
[Music]
rip you out like a
[Music]
god you guys got it right it like grows
on you it grows it does i've watched it
so many [ __ ] times watch it 50 days
it brings me so much joy every single
time you play it again honestly i can't
stop watching it the thing that this
music video reminded me of is
we picked our winner didn't we
for the contest yeah we did
oh i mean
okay
[Laughter]
what are you saying
i'm saying so we were
segue hey you know what's so funny oh
nick looked like he's about to tell a
ghost story
where is that lighting coming from oh
it's its own thing
it's horrible but
[Laughter]
do you have a ghost story for us
do you have any and was from wisconsin
dude like come on dude
show them things
wait how
what's the size of your town
50 2008 18. dude this one in springfield
missouri
i think they're like 200. you know the
specific data too that's really current
oh yeah this is diehard lacrosse he
takes the census every year
he's the one that does that
i'm a numbers guy you're going to think
i'm going to know that you don't have
relationships uh
i got something you know i'm going to
have to think i'm trying i am racking my
brain for what i was just going to say
earlier so uh you guys know we can only
pull out two things that one thing at
once you hit that pin yeah you guys
yeah
waverly's not a haunted house there's
something
no it's
it's something in louisville kentucky
yeah like a haunted house
it's like
it might be it used to be a same asylum
or whatever it's in waverly i think it's
ohio waverly that's ohio but yeah
they're a big haunted house community
meatball type in louisville house
community
in san jose we have the winchester house
they made a movie about that one
is that eddie murphy
no not that one that's the haunted
mansion very close though very close
damn winchester house
we're back welcome back to nick's ghost
story we've seen too much talent to just
like that's that's it we have to do a
versus on cats after dark i need to see
hear that guy rap against number five
okay yeah i mean the one that won we
should put him on the album but we could
still do a versus yeah i'm down uh-huh
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah i just mean a
continual segment oh yeah yeah i'm not
[ __ ] with you
oh okay
i thought or declared word word damn you
really hit this man i know hey shout out
to springfield missouri that's that's
where i got this i didn't know weed was
legal in springfield yeah damn
i stand by it i mean
i think i think a lot of places
like you know went to
legalization yeah you know that yeah
uh you know what i heard in wisconsin
the reason it's not legal because they
they're generally like kind of a
rowdier state in most respects i feel
like liberal too
but the tavern league which is like the
the governing body of bars doesn't want
it to be legal because they think it'll
like takes away from like hurt hurt the
business of alcohol yeah of course
they do
i've heard this they think they think
weed is going to stop people from
drinking it keeps me from drinking
it's a
i think it's our like uh
bro you ain't yeah
but y'all ever have the [ __ ] spins
the spin oh you got him right now when
you do like weed and drink and then
you're like oh it'll catch you yeah i
never had that i got it i'm just
drinking there was one time i had uh i
did uh nyquil no dayquil oh yeah that
closed my [ __ ] though oh let's go and i
don't know and i was doing it because i
was
i was doing it because i had a cold but
then i drank
like shortly after it alcohol drank
alcohol and then smoked [ __ ] pukes
that's right brains out you're robo
tripping bro that robocharge is what
they call that that's for robot testing
but yeah i've done that before
accidentally yeah i didn't mean it you
don't have to lie it's fine yeah no
because you you know where the body i
have a bigger body so i wanted a bigger
dose is this when you were a bigger guy
too i was probably more muscular and
she's not really okay fit just now i was
a bigger guy yeah okay but i remember
thinking like i would have taken more of
everything just before it would affect
me so i took the wrong one though i said
we're protesting but like the date like
the day one i did that and then i was
just flipping out the entire day
and it changed my life for like two
three
years you know years i mean yeah wait
wait i had like anxiety
uh something called depersonalization
like you feel like you're looking
through a fish lens or a dreamlike thing
i've had that before really it's kind of
like blurry double vision noise it's
almost like you know when you fight or
flight yeah you feel like you're out of
body wow
fight or flight for two years the
difference between that because i kept
fighting it dissociation the same thing
same thing okay god i got it because i
kept fighting it i didn't realize just
just stopped and then yeah
we've all experienced that too right
that's scary as [ __ ] dude a demon
attacking you know when you're sleeping
when you're trying to wake up and you
can't wake up oh hey dad yeah it's scary
you've never had that no i've always
heard about it my family growing up
they're very superstitious and they
would tell me that the only reason why
someone would have sleep paralysis is
because they're like
spiritually weak like they don't believe
in like god or buddha or whatever and so
like i don't know much about that i
always thought i was a woman of faith
because i never had the sleep paralysis
demon visit me but i was also taking too
much nyquil and i didn't realize it was
a problem until i got older
so wait you got sleep paralysis on no i
know she's never no i never had it i
attribute it to my faith in the good
lord and i quote
like like an actual demon
you just feel like you can't move and
like some people think there's like
something hovering over them yeah likes
holding them down like
yeah yeah like a spirit or something
holding you down i mean not
i don't know if they're doing it not
like that because they're moving too
much that's too much
[Laughter]
i am the man you see
[Laughter]
wait your chain is robo tripping just
lean or no it's not even lean it's
literally if you just take too much
robotus in
really a certain amount some people
would and
everyone out there do not try this but
some people will take a
half a bottle or something crazy oh wow
and they'll robo trip yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
let's just throw up honestly
yeah
no i'm saying that no that's what they
do to like robo trip they drink the
robots and they throw up and then after
they throw up they trip oh after they
throw up oh so they want to throw i
think so how much do they drink of it
like a bot like a half a bottle or
something
and they drink it slow like they're
pacing they're not like
[ __ ] chugging this robot i think they
chug it by the way see it ruined my life
for like three four three four years
so just be very careful don't do it huh
you have a ptsd no no but i mean i
remember the experience it was insane it
was crazy anxiety was insane the
depersonalization was insane like i
couldn't figure it out do you hear about
irwin rivera
no
he was uh i asked chin because he he
fought in mma he fought
no the the reason i took a deep breath
is because the story is so [ __ ] up
it did feel like a ghost story
there he goes to the ghost story you
look like you buy a campfire right now
telling the story i know there was like
a lot like a letter i was like gosh like
nick's ready irvin rivera was in the ufc
[Laughter]
but he fought a pretty competitive fight
uh which even reflecting back against
cheek gigachi godzilla okay that uh they
went to decision and he he performed
very very well and looking back i mean
gigas he was a killer yeah yeah so but
then he eventually got cut from the ufc
six months ago
there were news reports he got arrested
he stabbed his sisters damn
and
he went to jail and i hadn't i never
heard a follow-up on the story but
evidently he
pled guilty for by reason of insanity
and for some reason he hadn't slept for
seven days i think i remember this now
and he fought on for he fought on friday
for khabib's
organization eagle fc in florida
and in my opinion
in no way should have been sanctioned to
fight like
even if he's like better now the
likelihood that his psychosis even
though he's awake for saving seven days
is somehow cte related is
it's insane that they allowed him to
fight but he fought he won he won and he
had the craziest post-fight speech ever
and i mean he was just like he was like
i'm here to just tell you mental health
uh is real
uh it can happen to anyone i've never
done drugs i've never i've done all the
right things uh everybody who knows me
would say that but it my mind turned on
me and and and he's like my sister's
here
uh i didn't know she would be like
it's a crazy that is [ __ ] crazy
so she didn't die
no
i remember at least she didn't i i
thought two got stabbed this was all
recent
no it's a while and the last one in the
last year was the stab yeah yeah but the
fight was friday
last weekend do we want to watch the
post fight interview or no uh if you
found it yeah do you find it meatball
and i'm a hikano bro we come to fight i
don't care what if it's in this cage i
don't care if it's outside we come to
fight you know and uh it makes me proud
to honor my my my henry cejudo announced
this and at one point
he's henry who i mean he's the king of
cringe self-titled he says himself but
he was like he was like irwin doesn't he
irwin wants blood he doesn't care if
it's his he doesn't care if it's someone
else's irwin wants blood
that's [ __ ]
that's terrible but hilarious at the
same time yeah
my country but more than anything
tonight was very special
this was my first fight
in
almost two years a whole year i believe
i was locked up for murder charges here
in the state of florida they tried to
give me the electric chair they told me
i wasn't [ __ ] they treated me like a
[ __ ] animal every [ __ ] day and i
didn't break every [ __ ] day
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] making me mad
maybe we wanted him break them but these
[ __ ] man i [ __ ] told myself
i need to work hard i need to remain
calm and make sure more than anything i
see my little girl when i come out i
have a five-year-old little girl she was
taken away from me
bro my lone life has been [ __ ] crazy
but i'm still standing i'm still going
strong and i'm not ain't going nowhere
er well my question is but you had a
beautiful moment with your sister right
now how inspirational is that to have
your sister in the corner
what does it mean to have familia in
your corner oh it's everything
because i didn't think that you would be
here
yeah my whole story like i told you is
crazy
you know
insanity is something that's very very
real
i tell everybody what happened to me
could happen to anybody i don't do drugs
i don't [ __ ] i do everything right
everybody who knows me they know i do
everything right i always do everything
right i don't have mental trauma i don't
have crazy
crazy [ __ ] nothing
i went insane because my mind corrupted
me the mind can corrupt anybody i didn't
sleep for eight days and i went insane
and that would happen to anybody but it
happened to me and i'm here to tell you
guys i live i'm alive and i'm here to
tell you guys insanity is very real it's
very real so please
everybody just please
be careful
sleep is very important
very inspirational
for seven days
i haven't heard it either i haven't
heard it either remember rampage
remember rampage jackson yeah he had
that episode do you guys remember this
he was in a high speed chase with his
monster truck i didn't know that he
didn't sleep for multiple days too
and then he kind of went insane i think
people that lose sleep [ __ ] like that
can possibly happen you're not yourself
so you're going to psychosis yeah sleep
deprivation and combined with
possibilities yeah
yeah the ct thing is always on the back
of my mind but i don't who knows i i
just i just want to read her like he
seems f i'm not saying there's anything
like
it's not punitive why i say he shouldn't
be allowed to fight it's because i don't
think it's safe for someone who's
experienced an episode like that yeah
exactly until he gets like mris and
they're like yeah they check out his
brain and [ __ ] like it seems wild to
allow him to fight this one on my vibe
can we play that rap video again
let's get it back i like it
[Music]
one of the craziest things
what else can you do with me what else
can you play i'll show you okay
[Music]
in the forehead
[Music]
that was at some haunted ass theater in
edward washington was was that the
weekend the uh homeless guy game yeah
was that the the weekend that homeless
dude yeah
no what they try to stab you not me oh
who
i don't know i've had some homeless
people come at me before uh no someone
it was in we were in seattle no tacoma
and um
we just pulled up to the club in this
you know regular
well whatever there's this dude [ __ ]
arguing with this homeless guy yeah and
he took the homeless dude's beer you
know like sometimes like they're just
schizophrenic so they just like kind of
talk to themselves and stay in their
world but i guess he got too close to
the dude and he was like what the [ __ ]
are you doing and i'm looking at him
like yo leave the dude alone like leave
the homeless dude alone like [ __ ]
he's chilling then he took the homeless
dude's beer
dude flipped bruh he so like
because it was right outside the comedy
club and then
all of a sudden like we could walk
inside because he started going crazy
and then he [ __ ] threw the bottle
in there and it [ __ ] splat hit the
wall justin cut his head
all this [ __ ] not too bad with it like
he did cut it enough to where like a
good amount of blood was coming out dude
was trying to run up to like justin
uncut yeah justin
justin uncut yeah he was
justin
just
cut just sadly then so we're all in the
green room
and we're all like kind of freaking out
we're all trying to like get out of the
green room because the dude was like
trying to run in who took the who took
it from him the beer from some dude that
was just coming to see the show oh the
word yeah it'd be like a good city and
then brendan breaks the door to the
green room because it you know
to get out
and then we didn't realize
that that was the stage so we were all
on stage and all those people were like
yay
[Music]
here we go again
big brother yep
nice nick you are good at this game
graduation my [ __ ] i can help you
track wonder oh i know
my favorite my favorite track
my favorite track of that album is uh i
wonder yeah
and then the next one that's seven and
my skip is drunken hot girls dude what
the [ __ ] is that song
although it's growing on me that's all
types of songs too i don't know
yeah that's a fair skill yeah that's the
first thing it's long it's repetitive
it's
just watching the video they want to
watch the documentary i told you to
bring back the rapper video yeah oh [ __ ]
just one time
we did it ourselves floor head starts to
glisten yeah i'm trying to find out i
kind of want to take that lyric and flip
it into a beat and be like so hot for
forehead starts to glisten yeah my
flow's so hot
off the ground
you almost know all the lyrics
[Music]
so listen i got much time to describe
what i gotta prescribe my patients i see
you standing right there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
check them out take them out
[Music]
come on everyone
hey
yeah
we've given him so many plays
we're promoting it's like when a radio
station plays that number
like yo i gotta play this track again
bringing you back with uh gentiles now i
forget his [ __ ]
ig name jim towel
yeah
that's from rush hour gentile
oh
what's this [ __ ] instagram again
i don't know but that kid's lit he's so
lit
we're zooming in our boy now let's go
shout out to erica
send me some stuff
i'll be waiting to try it out okay did
you ever get your uh promo code dark
going on oh uh so only fans does not do
promo code but i did 50 off subscription
for a month why yeah so you can get it
for five dollars instead of 10. you hear
that kristen
50 off yeah fifty percent off her only
only what's your promo code
guys i gotta go i need to go home and do
some stuff
we were trying to give something special
to cats
after dark fans but yeah they don't have
any promo codes unfortunately i would do
uh all these subscription websites have
like [ __ ] tech like patreon yeah it's
not very user friendly i will say that's
the biggest caveat to having a
subscription-based
like
content creation situation it's just
like it's kind of like the bare minimum
and then they start adding [ __ ] later
but i think what was it isn't instagram
one of those apps who are adding
subscriptions to their feed like they're
testing it out right now
i haven't seen it what's happening i
think instagram is in the process of
testing out subscription-based content
as well i heard that yes
i saw a announcement about it on
instagram i was like huh this is
interesting but then someone else made
an app kind of like only fans minus the
like sexual content yeah i forgot what
was called it's called like camera roll
or something and so people will send you
like post photos of things that they
don't post online so it could be like
their screenshots from the camera
rolling you see like text messages that
they screenshot from people randomly
really or like photos that they just
don't post otherwise
and it's a subscription-based yeah
yeah
that's cool that'd be really easy to
post stuff too just all the old stuff
you don't yeah
but then i don't know how many people
are willing to pay for something like
that yeah because i saw a few creators
uh like
they were on board for the initial
launch and they were being selective
about who they chose to
be like one of the first creators on the
app but then i haven't heard anything of
it yeah i think
it's like there's just so many ways to
like
get free content yeah
you know what i mean so i guess some
people probably like
you know could be weird about it i think
there's so many variations of the same
thing but also like you know people want
to subscribe look at meatball
i love it put it on your own screen
you got this meatball
basically anytime you're doing something
even like google searching just do it on
your own and then you can bring it up
damn nick hi is the kite he's still got
this production thing down i see you
though
i see you yeah
and then
look at that protruding everybody
yeah i was watching the teaching process
some of you guys are co-pilots
oh speaking of homeless people uh
steve and i almost got robbed by a
homeless man a few weeks ago
we used to rob you uh nothing we just we
were out at dinner and i guess because
we always take his car when we go out to
eat and hit the clicker for the garage
is on the passenger side seat so i think
what happened was as we were leaving i
might have put down the like
little flap to go look in the mirror and
i must have accidentally clicked the
button and opened up our garage as we
were pulling back into the house after
dinner there was this like homeless
looking guy who was kind of like walking
with the scooter and for a second stevie
and i were looking like huh that's
interesting it's a scooter and stevie's
scooter has like this little basket on
it so like in half a second we both
registered like i think that's your
scooter and so stevie's like rolls down
the windows like hey that's my scooter
and the guy tries to run off not knowing
how to turn the scooter on
running with this like big clunky
scooter and stevie just pulls the car up
in front
he drops it he leaves and we try to back
up to see where like what's happening
with our garage and our garage is wide
open so we're freaking out like what
happened and as we're looking at the
garage the homeless guy runs back to the
scooter tries to grab it one more time
drop it
like i'm right here
i don't give a
[Laughter]
but he ends up just leaving we grabbed
the scooter put it back in the garage
and we're trying to figure out how he
got in and that's the conclusion we came
to but we're just like oh you almost got
robbed yeah of your scooter his prize
possession i have a quick i have a quick
uh scooter homeless story i have to tell
really really fast just because okay go
no no i i want to hear you yes but but
for homeless people on uh the other
podcast i do we myriad
of
homeless people stories we call them
zombies and there's different types
there's different types of zombies
there's definitely harmless zombies i
really thought he was going to be like
we should call him something else
besides like a nicer name
he's trying to be all progressively like
yo we
but i mean there's like there's like i
mean down on their luck zombies there's
this sounds like the storyline
of zombies and this is uh a piece of
[ __ ] scooter steeler zombie i don't know
if that's a specific category but yeah
yeah so
this one was bad well this one was um
one guy gets [ __ ] taken off their
porch
every other day from
a bridge zombie
for sure there's so many categories i
love that he has his hands folded out
he's like educating us on the different
kinds of zombies
that's actually um
no just this person so my boy my friend
freddy was riding a scooter right his
girlfriend he's a [ __ ] scooter stealing
zombie zombie yeah pretty much but this
was a stick throwing zombie oh
different breeds
yeah they're both riding scooters my
friend freddy's in front his uh fiance's
right beside him riding a bird just down
santa monica this homeless person comes
out of nowhere and just throws a stick
like big daddy style in front of her big
daddy's style in front of the girl right
i've told this story before it's funny
but
hits the in front of the scooter that
his girl was riding and she flies off
the bird and like skids off the street
like it was a bad fall like oh of course
like skids off the thing
and he just went fight or flight and
goes what the [ __ ] and runs up to the
homeless person and clocks them in the
side of the head and just like like that
like hit the concrete like it looked
like he killed them like he just hit
them so hard
and he goes what the [ __ ] was that and
the person had their hood over their
face like uh kenny from south park like
just like this yeah so he couldn't tell
who it was and the person goes uh uh and
pulled the thing off and goes i'm a
woman
and she's like and i have cancer and
he's like oh my god no i'm so sorry so
for like weeks he was just saying like i
beat up a homeless lady this is that
no i'm with your friend on that just
because she's a woman and has cancer
doesn't mean she doesn't deserve her ass
beat after that
i know all right meatball you [ __ ]
okay rhode island yeah right yeah
what is this
over here
you're the one
i [ __ ] agree with your friend
i side with your friends on this yeah i
decided with your [ __ ] friend
our broken we got our boy on the line
let's go
who's that
is that oh bro
bro
so he can see you too oh sure yeah
because well he can only see us
oh no no uh we can switch we can switch
those cameras oh you guys okay remember
last time he was only like
able to focus on us uh yeah fix that he
upped it hi
oh
[Music]
yet uh hello hello meatball are you
recording
this you can hear me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
uh-oh what's up
guys how are you doing what's going on
congrats
thanks for having me on i appreciate it
yeah
hey bro so recording in progress we
loved your song you you won the contest
so you won the contest or you're gonna
be on the album with us
really
i seen the pose it looked like it was
going to do the same thing again so i
figured you know
i mean it's all i feel like i already
won anyway as soon as soon as i seen
chin bump into my [ __ ] i felt like i
wanted already yeah
that's tight [ __ ] dude
wait where are you based out again
connecticut
what do you say connecticut connecticut
okay
yeah yeah
hartford
close to it like 30 minutes away from
harvard let me guess new haven
no other way more towards you oh [ __ ] oh
more towards meatballs
yeah
it's like new london oh oh damn
is that real close to you it's like
45 minutes i think oh yeah oh damn yeah
how long have you been making music for
probably like 15 years
you got a dope voice we've been writing
and [ __ ] you know yeah
so yeah i seen little browns come up on
the podcast that's that really inspired
me man that's that's hell yeah god's
done his truth man oh hell yeah that's
awesome yeah that's what we want to do
just pay it forward and give someone
else a shot and i feel like you're kind
of a hidden gem
so you know it's going to be miu and
chin on a song
that's fire
i don't even know that's crazy man i
don't even know what to say that's wild
[Laughter]
big shout out to that dude man he did
kill it man he did oh yeah yeah yeah he
did these guys
submissions as soon as i seen the first
one i was like oh [ __ ] it's a rap i'm
out of here
when i seen the dude singing on the
guitar but i was like okay and y'all
showed me to show me the love i was like
that's what's up man yeah shout out to
arthur
a-r-t-h-v-r he check his music out he's
really dope but uh yeah the fans voted
and i think you're you're a good fit for
the project so we're excited to have you
on it bro yes that's crazy
what'd you think of that everlast
comparison
i like that over the last i'm [ __ ]
everlast see hey who did that compare
did i do that
okay
yeah yeah i appreciate that chapelle
yeah i got you dawg i appreciate you
saying my name of your song if you watch
if you have a message for a white mike
who is uh
kind of trying to grow he's a cool guy
too
[Laughter]
there's one person to do it's white mike
[Laughter]
yeah he's cool that was funny as [ __ ]
damn i can't wait to hear this track me
too
me too yeah it's going to be great man
i want to hear a little bit about what
do you do are you making music full time
how do you nah i build houses that's
dope wow yeah true true cats fan man oh
damn
yeah
that's [ __ ] strong yeah
yeah you know
that's like some man [ __ ] that's amazing
but i hate it though i hate it
noble profession
[Laughter]
yeah early like five in the morning yeah
and you gotta go to bed right now
probably yeah
who's some of your musical influences
you have like a really cool tone to your
voice
yeah i mean all over the place you know
i'm a i'm a big ass fan of kid rock
believe it or not
i believe back in a date i might go
crazy right now but i love i love kid
rock love eminem
uh love rock and roll hip hop all types
of music you know okay hell yeah
i can't really come off the top right
now with all the artists that i've
listened to and everything that i really
[ __ ] with because i'm a little nervous
and i'm on the show is that a fish tank
behind you that's what i thought too
nah sorry it's my little studio
oh
damn that's dope my little thousand
dollar setup i got hell yeah
that's all you need and you recorded
that song right right there in this
studio
right here yeah
damn yeah that was good hello mike my
brother sounded really really good yeah
that sounds great that's a thousand
dollars
thousand dollars for all this equipment
yeah pretty much
for us 100
yeah no you have
yeah so it's a craftsman what was that
recording you know what was that slow
song on the the first like kid rock big
c cd
oh my god knows why only god knows why
that was on my fall sleep playlist
i [ __ ] got song
[Applause]
i'll jump in once you give it to me
[Music]
something about pills
[Applause]
at some point he talks about pills
[Laughter]
hey bro thank you so much for submitting
your song and uh i haven't really
announced this yet but so it's gonna be
miu and chin on a song and we got a ton
of cool features on the album so you're
gonna be on there with chappelle with uh
mark harley's got a song on there jelly
roll mike stud
um a bunch of other comedians
going there so it's an album chock full
of some cool people so we're excited to
have you on the track
i know i've been following you brows
i've been seeing them let's go
[Laughter]
i've been following bro that's just fine
i can't believe this it's for real i
can't believe that [ __ ] well you earned
it how's that gonna work though since
i'm like thousands of miles away from
these guys you got the setup bro right
in the fish tank send it over
i'm going to hit you after this and let
you know
absolutely but good [ __ ] bro
congratulations
you're amazing
thank you brother
all right
hell yeah all right good [ __ ] all right
good [ __ ] man thank you all right good
day bye we'll talk to you soon everybody
bye
have a good day at work tomorrow i know
two hours
super cool dude i know i mean that was
the exact purpose of it yeah he was like
you inspired me and you wanted to give
the same opportunity that you did
something else for real
girl
listen you get down when you know lyrics
you jump in that much i haven't heard
that for a long time
it hasn't been in the roto for
he was really vibing though yeah
something about pills
he had the head down
he was waiting for that one
but then it's when you're saying i was
like oh i remember that song i i do not
remember that song oh it's dope yeah
yeah i don't think i've heard that one
you listen listen to it after i bet i
bet you have i don't know is it on the
album with bob with the ball yeah and it
was like uh
i think it was a single and it did not
do well like as well because yeah with
the ball cowboy yeah those two popped
off and that was i think that was on it
damn it it was a big song though i don't
know if it was as big as the other yeah
yeah yeah it was a big song it was trl
it was on yeah
he's on the porch in black and white i
think he's got a dope drummer he's had
her he's had uh she's drunk for him for
[ __ ] years yeah she's a beast oh wow
i forget her name uh black lady with
curly hair
golden curly hair
no she's been his drummer for like years
one day we're gonna release the uh the
two
the the two
first half lost episodes uh just camera
only audio
oh yeah it's like grading to my ears we
need
we actually do need our own social media
accounts but like
i don't want to put more on your plate
so if anybody wants to
work for free
there's a different way of wording it if
anyone wants to be an intern yeah we're
going to do cats after dark american
idol for our new social media person who
does not get paid
insurance
intern
[Laughter]
paid an experience
but
honestly because there's a lot
even during this episode
when uh he
was like oh for real i won the vote or
whatever yeah it reminded me of like
when dave portman was doing the bar
stool fund he was calling up like yeah
uh like businesses and like they they
like uh they were just circumcised
during the pandemic yeah yeah yeah and
they would tear up when they heard the
news that they were getting like this
money to float them uh one time on
uh
this past weekend yeah you got it yeah
theo knows that that single mom's night
out thing and he wouldn't
he would have them call in
he would he would give a single mother a
night out
okay he would pay for a babysitter have
him come to the show they could bring a
friend
uh and then when they got back we'd do a
follow-up with him and just kind of he'd
chat with him and then he would surprise
them with like 500 dollars
and one time i did not have this
coincidentally i did not have the zoom
recording like her face when she like
she like broke and she was like oh my
god like because the 500 is like
changing your life and we didn't get
that reaction you heard it
mentioned that story does it
nick every time you tell stories like
that i could just see it like these are
the things that haunt you at least
like just looming over your head you're
like oh my god you got to get them out
every once in a while yeah there's good
memories too
that's the drummer lady for uh kid rock
yeah yeah she's been with them for
[ __ ] years it looks like dozier cat's
mom yeah it is oh cool you ought to know
that
she's bigger there
that they're looking doja cat's face a
little bit like just like
should we get some plugs in
close up shop let's close up shop yeah i
got a
hike hot date with a hike
you're a looking
swimmer just take the compliment
chappelle i don't know if he's being
real or not
take it how you want it it probably
isn't
that'd be negative
i took it negative all right
when you say it
negative it's fair anyways let's plug
some stuff uh what's everybody got going
on christian what do you got going on
absolutely nothing um you can just find
me on instagram see palo 6 and oh
actually i did do a video with my friend
isaiah miranda so if you go to youtube
look up uh look him up i appreciate that
that's about it nick nice
uh
tomorrow
now because we release this on fridays
yep i'm gonna be
uh live streaming and actually
the ufc card starts at 10 a.m on
saturday because it's in london right
yeah yeah and it's a dope card our boy
jack shore yeah yeah
that's that's sick patty the baddie's on
it patty the body and jack shore i
cannot wait for patio batty i know that
scuffle
this sucks
i love it
i just love this car
yeah yeah
what about what no we're talking the
scuffle
yeah but he's not fighting either which
i was like oh damn that sucks he's
finding someone else oh you want he's
not even fighting that guy no no
not yet i know yeah
but ufc is not going to do that for a
while because i think paddy the betty
would get beat if i'm going to be honest
and i hate that
i don't know there's lit there's hey
he's a scouser i know i love scousers
but ilia tuperia is
probably future champ he's he's
i don't wanna i don't i love patty the
baddie so i wanna make that clear but
yeah jack shore is definitely gonna win
he's even money that's next pick he's
beating team or vallev
everywhere
he's been doing the damn thing are you
live streaming this you said oh yes
tomorrow
twitch.com
t underscore darsh that's my buddy's
twitch we just do it on his channel uh
the fights end the second round of uh
ncaa tournament all day oh yeah all day
will white mike be there uh yes
i don't know probably not definitely not
saturday maybe sunday we're gonna do it
both days but uh
god doesn't like fight so
not on saturday
white mike killed it shout out yeah
i tell people he's a funny funny funny
guy
cat yeah
onlyfans.com
teen for all that good [ __ ] it's half
off right now get it while it lasts
yeah
get it how long does it last for um i
haven't made up my mind yet i'm gonna
probably keep it up for a month
uh just me my name chinh c-h-i-n-s-u-y-i
on instagram and youtube and also if
anyone has been to the great lakes i'm
trying to do a trip there for a weekend
if you have any advice on good fishing
spots which lake in particular is good
let me know please
thank you
ross instagram youtube at little browse
drop in some music soon just be on the
lookout damn i love it uh i'll be
reviewing how is that dude
i love it
jackson i love it anyways i'll be you
know is that how i sound it
this is like a radio podcast
over to you chappelle
i'm just mad about my voice because i
lost it from singing it sounds good it
sounds fine yeah it does it sounds great
yeah i like the right
a little different but yeah you can hear
your audible [ __ ] all right
thank you so much
dog uh april 8th and april 9th i'll be
in
salt lake city at wiseguys comedy club
may 6th and 7th
new comedy club in san diego called mic
drop comedy club
one nighter in phoenix may 12th
at uh stand up live and then also uh
purchase my merch scroll up a little bit
yeah that oh you were right there your
level is tight
your merch is dope you guys like it i do
yeah i do yeah support my
merch
i have that blue one i wear it all the
time this one i have that one that's my
favorite thing it's great quality yeah
you know my favorite of them huh i love
uh my crew neck
yeah that uh black and blue one i like
that one too can i get it
you don't
the the no on the right that one yeah
that one's five i'll take one two three
oh you guys all one more there's only
one smaller i have one
it's great what does it say one there's
only small sizes left
and one double xl yeah i need a large
bro
anyways all right thank you guys for
tuning in uh also like nick said
make sure you subscribe or follow on
apple audio yeah uh apple podcast or
spotify as well boom don't
what i tried to say dope
you said don't
all right
[Music]
[Music]
bye